you might have heard about stable
diffusion and how it's cool and can do
so much generating any imagery you can
think of one thing it cannot do is
incorporate my extremely special dogs
but through text inversion you can teach
stable diffusion new things this is done
by adding new words to the embedding
space you only need three to five images
for a good result so just read the paper
and implement it yourself or Bop on over
to hugging face grab the notebook edit
some cells and do a bunch of shift
entering then train which can take a
couple hours but in the end you are
rewarded with the ability to incorporate
your specific thing as an object or even
General style for example this is a real
photo of my dog Willis from here after
training here's an example of output
from a prompt asking for a low poly
Willis here's a Minecraft Willis this is
another one of my dogs her name is
Squish here's a low poly Squish and a
Minecraft squish the possibilities here
are endless so go try it for yourself